I'm not necessarily in a prediction
business but let me tell you this if any
team has a chance to come back from a
3-0 deficit it is this year's Boston
Celtics and I'll tell you why they lose
both home games they lose their first
game in Boston so now they win the
fourth game in Miami it's now 3-1 the
next two out of three games are in
Boston that's interesting they have to
win this home game in Boston and they
gotta win it convincingly if they win
game five in Boston I think the
momentum's in their favor I think
they're gonna be like you know what we
could actually do this all we got to do
is get to game seven because it will be
on their home floor it's the perfect
scenario it's gonna be like a great
Sports story it's gonna be a great watch
it'll be the sports Story of the Year